the Marine Corps acknowledges a
maintenance issue that caused a deadly
military plane crash should have been
detected 15 Marines and a sailor died
when a kc-130 aircraft broke apart and
crashed in Mississippi last year Marine
Forces reserve investigation found a
problem with the plane that should have
been fixed years ago David Martin spoke
with the victims Widow he's at the
Pentagon David good morning good morning
when this crash happened it seemed like
the airplane just fell out of the sky
for no reason now we know why and we
also know this accident could and should
have been prevented it kills me inside
because my children could still have
their dad I could still help my husband
Ashleigh kindred has been waiting 17
months for the briefing she got this
week from the Marine Corps about what
caused last year's crash of a c-130 that
killed her husband Staff Sergeant
William Kandra and 15 others it's hard
to know that he's been gone so many
times and deployed all around the world
but then he he dies on American soil the
transport plane a workhorse of the
American military had simply disappeared
from radar during the routine
cross-country flight the plane
callsign Yankee 72 was at 20,000 feet
when without warning a blade on the left
inboard propeller flew off and sliced
through the fuselage a 130 pound object
traveling at almost the speed of sound
that caused so much structural stress
the right inboard propeller came off and
spun into the fuselage the cockpit was
severed from the plane and plummeted to
earth followed moments later by the
fuselage the doomed aircraft belonged to
an Air Wing commanded by Brigadier
General Bradley James you know the
question every family's going to ask did
my husband did my son suffer that
question that is the number one question
and my answer has been I'd like to think
that they did not law the wreckage was
strewn across five miles of Mississippi
soybean fields
that's the propeller blade which
triggered the fatal sequence of events
the investigation found tiny pits of
roshun which over time had become a
crack that caused the blade to fail when
did that corrosion occur we tracked this
back when it went to rework around 2011
so a failure to detect corrosion in 2011
causes this fatal crash in 2017 yes
in 2011 the propeller had undergone a
scheduled overhaul at this maintenance
center at Warner Robins Air Force Base
in Georgia Krueger tier General John Q
benek is the current commander the
procedures that were in place at 2011
those procedures if properly done should
have detected that corrosion in 2011 why
it wasn't we don't know this could have
been prevented
the guys could still be here with us
today had they just done their job but
determining exactly who what the
overhaul facility was responsible may be
impossible in 2011 maintenance records
were destroyed after only two years I
definitely have more questions and I'm
sure I'll get them answered sergeant
Conrad had been a marine for 15 years
and done nine overseas tours like all
the others onboard that plane he never
had a chance
sergeant Kundra leaves behind his wife
and their two children I'm gonna tell
them you know daddy should still be here
with us and I know it will hurt them
they're so proud of him and he's their
hero and he always will be
as a result of this accident the Air
Force suspended its overhaul of c-130
propeller blades until it could be sure
a mistake like this would not happen
again
John David we reported on a story this
morning of a similar plane and an
accident is there any relationship
between the two well of course we don't
know yet what caused that accident out
in Japan but it would seem unlikely this
plane that we have just been talking
about was on a cross-country flight
flying straight and level with no other
aircraft around it in the middle of the
day the plane in Japan was conducting
training aerial refueling training in
which two planes are operating in very
close proximity to each other in the
middle of the night
all right thank you David it's hard not
to feel heartbroken and angry when you
hear Ashleigh Kandra see that this
possibly could have been prevented
sounds like we can do some more
investigative reporting on this in terms
why those maintenance records were
destroyed and whether they're not
following up correctly on this